[Music]  hi drew it's eitan thank you for having  me on this edition of cookbook club i'm  excited to recommend my own cookbook a  tiny swirl's available pre-order  everywhere books are sold and you've  already got a peek at it but a recipe i  don't know if you caught when you were  looking at it for your blurb that i  think you're going to love is my casa  vitrano olive pesto pasta it is kind of  like a combination between olive  tapenade and pesto bam into one sauce on  pasta it is just delicious it is  heartwarming it is just a happy pasta  dish that i think you are going to love  and everyone else it is delicious it is  fun to make and it is an aton eats the  world trust me you are going to love it  thank you for letting me be part of  drew's cookbook club